Good morning, John.
It’s Friday.
Not just any Friday, my darling John; it is
Friday, 11/11.
What’s the big deal about that?
I have no idea, but sometimes, 11:11 is a
time where you see people tweet, “Make a
wish!” and I have no idea why, and I could
Google it right now, but frankly, I can’t be bothered.
But why can’t I be bothered?
Because it’s also the first Friday of President-Elect
Trump’s president-electionry.
President-electioncy?
I don’t know.
Yes, that’s right everybody, we voted for
Donald Trump to be President!
I didn’t in particular.
I don’t know how many of you did, but people
did.
Some people voted for Donald Trump to be President.
Moreover, 46% of people didn’t vote at all.
For those of you that don’t know who I am,
my name is Hannah Hart.
I have a YouTube channel called Harto.
I am most well known for a show called My
Drunk Kitchen, and most beloved for putting
my feelings all over the internet.
But I don’t want to talk about me or how
incredible I am.
I want to talk about the trouble with wishing,
because it occurs to me that wishes are what
got us here, and it occurs to me that wishing
is what made 46% of our population not vote.
But let’s talk about the good thing about
wishes.
What a wish is is your heart’s desires.
It’s what you truly want.
It’s what you truly want to be true.
It’s what you truly want to see.
It’s what you truly want to do.
So in that way, a wish is a great thing because
it shows you things about yourself you might
not otherwise know.
What’s the trouble with this wonderful thing?
Well, it gets you into something called wishful
thinking, where you think you can do less
and still get what you want.
Now I don’t want to blame us for what just
happened, but I am going to blame us.
Yeah, I know.
It’s not our fault, but also, maybe it is.
So in terms of ourselves and our hopes and
wishes and dreams and trying to turn those
thoughts into actions and those actions into
events of change, I think we probably took
that action for ourselves, but what I worry
we didn’t do is have enough conversations
with other people in our families.
I’m just gonna say that.
It’s a beautiful and wonderful thing that
we were motivated enough to vote as millennials
this year, that we had such a strong turnout,
and I think that the next step is talking
to those members of our family and the people
in our lives who perhaps hold alternative
political beliefs to ours or live in a world
of apathy.
I am confident that there is someone in your
family that voted for Donald Trump and/or
didn’t vote at all.
On a positive note, I do think it is an extraordinary
thing to live in a country where we can still
act in accordance with our beliefs, and while
we can still do so, I think we should.
While it is still safe for us to have these
uncomfortable dinner conversations, I would
like you to do so.
If there is a member of your family that you
know has opposing political beliefs to you,
I know it is awkward, but show them your Twitter
feed.
Show them the instances of racism and violence
that are already being incited in quote-unquote
Trump’s America.
If you have a friend that did not vote, show
them this, and if they’re like, “Well
that wasn’t me; I didn’t vote for Trump,”
tell them, “But you didn’t vote at all.”
Therefore, they are guilty by association.
I know you would like to pretend like your
actions don’t matter, but sorry, your actions
and inactions matter a lot.
So while we take this time to heal and mourn
and grieve, which I implore you to do so because
to rebuild your strength, you really need
to rest for a second, I also would like to
caution you to stay away from wishful thinking.
It turns out that what we thought was enough
isn’t enough, so we can’t cross our fingers
for next time.
We can’t cross our fingers that in two years
we’re gonna elect a congress more in line
with our beliefs.
We have to start having those conversations
now.
And John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.
Or at youtube.com/harto.
Also, I hope you guys enjoyed this dramatic
lighting.
It is a dramatic time, which is so exciting.
Mwah.